Tras la victoria de Donald Trump frente a
Hillart Clinton el referéndum del Brexit
y la Alt-right extendiendo sus tentáculos
por media Europa, las elecciones presidenciales
de Francia de 2017 fueron consideradas por
muchos como la última muralla contra el populismo
y en favor del civismo y la tolerancia.
Ahora, 5 años después, la historia en cierto
modo se repite.
Ante las presidenciales francesas, son muchos
los candidatos y los periodistas que mencionan
la gran historia de este país y su extenso
compromiso con los derechos humanos.
Claro que la realidad puede ser algo diferente
y mucho menos épica.
Como dijo el General de Gaulle: “Francia
no puede ser Francia sin su grandeza”.
Cueste lo que cueste.
Porque podéis tener una cosa muy clara: la
política exterior no es precisamente un juego
de niños.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Realmente, siempre
ha sido Francia ese faro de la democracia
que afirman los políticos galos?
¿Por qué las acciones de este país se ven
tan diferentes fuera de Francia respecto a
cómo ellos mismos se ven desde dentro?
Queridos amigos, amigas, este vídeo va a
ser un poquito diferente a los habituales.
En esta ocasión nos vamos a centrar en poner
sobre la mesa algunos de los grandes escándalos
con repercusión internacional que ha protagonizado
el país galo..
Esta es la otra cara de la república francesa.
Atentos.
Golpes de estado, campañas de represión,
secuestros y asesinatos.
La política exterior de Francia no siempre
se basa en la diplomacia suave, el dialogo
y el intercambio de opiniones.
A continuación vamos a echar un vistazo a
algunos de los supuestos grandes escándalos
internacionales en los que la república francesa
ha podido estar involucrada.
Escándalos que han alimentado todo tipo de
sospechas, teorías de la conspiración y
resquemores.
Algunos de ellos son rotundamente negados
por París, a pesar de lo cual existen muchos
motivos para dudar.
Otros son admitidos con la boca pequeña.
Dicho lo cual, sin más preámbulo, creo que
lo mejor es que pongamos algunos de ellos
sobre la mesa.
¿Y sabés qué?
El primero de ellos nos lleva ni más ni menos
que hasta Latinoamérica.
(LA OPERACIÓN CÓNDOR)
Durante la década de los 70 gran parte de
Sudamérica estuvo bajo el control de varias
dictaduras que dirigieron sus países con
mano de hierro.
Hablamos particularmente de Brasil, Argentina,
Chile, Paraguay, Bolivia y Uruguay.
Pues bien, el día 28 de noviembre de 1975
en Santiago de Chile los gobiernos de estos
países, con la excepción de Brasil - aunque
esto no fue impedimento para que luego participara
activamente - implementaron oficialmente el
conocido como Operación o Plan Cóndor:
Una campaña de represión política y terrorismo
de estado para perseguir a la oposición política,
particularmente a la oposición de izquierdas.
Hablamos de una dura campaña de represión
en la que participaron, en un momento u otro,
la mayoría de los gobiernos de Sudamérica
y que inclusó incluyo el asesinato de numerosos
opositores políticos.
El terror, amigo, recorrió el Cono Sur de
arriba a abajo y lo hizo con el firme apoyo
de Estados Unidos bajo los gobiernos de Gerald
Ford, Jimmy Carter y Ronald Reagan.
(Durante algo más de 10 años se llevaron
a cabo decenas de miles de detenciones, secuestros
y extradiciones irregulares.
Se utilizó ampliamente la tortura y algunas
estimaciones apuntan a que fueron más de
60.000 las victimas mortales que pueden atribuirse
al Plan Condor.
Víctimas entre las que figuraban guerrilleros
de izquierdas pero también disidentes políticos,
líderes sindicales, estudiantes, intelectuales,
profesores, sacerdotes y campesinos.)
Pues bien, la historia nos dice que los gobiernos
sudamericanos llevaron a cabo este plan con
el apoyo fundamentalmente de Estados Unidos.
Esta es la historia, pero puede no ser toda
la historia.
Particularmente en el caso de Argentina y
Chile.
Según se ha denunciado, algunos documentos
originales del Ministerio de Exteriores de
Francia que parecen probar un acuerdo en 1959
entre París y Buenos Aires para establecer
en la Argentina una misión militar permanente
de oficiales que habían luchado en la Guerra
de Argelia.
También, se sospecha que el gobierno del
Presidente Giscard, habría colaborado activa
y secretamente con la Junta de Vida en la
Argentina y el régimen de Augusto Pinochet
en Chile.
De esta forma, los franceses habrían entrenado
a los servicios de inteligencia de la dictadura
argentina, incluyendo formación en técnicas
de tortura.
Y no solo eso, los “decretos de aniquilación”
firmados por Isabel Perón parecen haberse
inspirado en documentos franceses anteriores.
(El propio Reynaldo Bignone, nombrado presidente
de la junta militar argentina en 1982 afirmó
que el orden de batalla del golpe de estado
que llevó a los militares argentinos al poder
en 1976 se había inspirado en la propia experiencia
francesa en Argelia.)
Blanco y en botella.
Luego, años más tarde en 2003 diputados
del partido verde francés solicitaron la
creación de una Comisión Parlamentaria para
examinar el papel de Francia a la hora de
apoyar activamente a los regímenes militares
de América del Sur.
Una comisión que no llegó a ninguna parte
porque el responsable de dicha comisión,
el diputado Roland Blum se negó a permitir
que declararan los testigos clave.
Amigos, el gobierno francés ha negado activamente
haber jugado ningún papel en el Plan Cóndor.
Sin embargo, existen muchos motivos para dudar.
En 2007, el almirante argentino Luis María
Mendía, declaró ante la justicia que la
inteligencia francesa había participado en
el secuestro y asesinato de dos monjas francessas
en el país gaucho.
A pesar de las negaciones de París, los indicios
parecen acumularse sobre la mesa.
Pero, no hemos hecho más que empezar.
Y si hay un territorio en el que la “diplomacia
francesa” es especialista ese no es otro
que África.
Atentos.
(EL TEATRO DE OPERACIONES GALO )
Hace ya más de 6 décadas, más de 60 años
que las colonias de Francia en África comenzaron
a independizarse.
Sin embargo pesar de ello, el papel del país
galo en el continente africano sigue siendo
tan intenso que incluso tiene su propia denominación:
"Françafrique" .
[Lo siento mi conocimiento del francés es
equivalente a mi capacidad
Hablamos de un concepto que trata de aglutinar
tanto la influencia política de Francia como
la influencia que también tienen las redes
clandestinas y repletas de corrupción y asuntos
turbios que siguen existiendo entre la vieja
metrópoli y sus antiguas colonias.
O mejor dicho con las élites con las élites
que controlan sus antiguas colonias.
Sea como sea, si una cosa ha tenido siempre
clara es que el gobierno de Francia es su
decidida vocación por intentar mantener su
influencia internacional y seguir siendo considerada
una superpotencia mundial.
Y en esa estrategia África juega un papel
clave.
Por eso, aunque hayan pasado 60 años el peso,
la influencia y el poder de Francia en gran
parte del continente africano sigue siendo
simple y llanamente enorme.
Un papel que durante la guerra fría fue,
además, apoyado por los mismísimos Estados
Unidos.
Queridos amigos, durante la Guerra Fría Francia
se convirtió en la punta de lanza de Occidente
para evitar que la región cayera bajo la
influencia soviética.
Un papel que en París se tomaron muy pero
que muy a pecho.
Francia tuvo un papel tan intervencionista
en África que desde 1960 hasta mediados los
90 lideró una media de una intervención
militar cada año.
[Si, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Es algo que prácticamente deja a Estados
Unidos y al mismísimo George W.
Bush como unos auténticos principiantes en
todo este tema de las intervenciones internacionales.]
Francia ha hecho prácticamente de todo: ha
intervenido para proteger a los ciudadanos
franceses, para sofocar una rebelión, para
evitar golpes de estado o para propiciarlos.
Incluso no ha dudado en eliminar a los presidentes
que suponían una amenaza para sus planes.
Esta es por ejemplo la lista de presidentes
africanos en cuya eliminación participó
Francia.
Atentos.
Sí, puede que la mayoría fueran sátrapas
de tomo y lomo, pero con esto os podéis hacer
una idea de cómo ha jugado Francia en la
región.
Y, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Tampoco podemos decir qué los resultados
fueran particularmente buenos…
Si dejamos a un lado los intereses de la propia
Francia, claro está.
Así que mucho hablar de los chinos en África,
pero luego…
(Para llevar a cabo esta estrategia no fueron
ni uno ni dos, sino tres los servicios de
inteligencia franceses que jugaron un papel
muy activo en la organización de golpes de
estado y “depuración” de líderes incómodos
u hostiles.
el Servicio de Documentación y Anti-Espionaje
Exterior, la DGSE y la DST)
Y eso no es todo.
Lo cierto es que podemos encontrar muchos
ejemplos de acciones muy pero que muy controvertidas.
(Por ejemplo, ahí está el caso del conocido
Angolagate, un enorme escándalo político
relacionado con la venta y envío secreto
de armas al gobierno de Angola durante la
década de los 90.
un escándalo que involucró a muchas de las
figuras más importantes de la política francesa.
Desde MitterRand a Jacques Chirac.)
Un caso aún mucho más oscuro es el del asesinato
en 1995 de Bernad Borrel, un magistrado francés
destinado en Yibuti que a día de hoy todo
apunta a que fue dado de baja por el propio
gobierno de Yibuti.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué?
Como en ese momento a Francia le interesaba
cuidar la relación con este país africano,
todo apunta a que asesoró a este gobierno
africano sobre cómo defenderse al tiempo
que también les filtró información importante
sobre las pesquisas policiales y judiciales
que estaban en marcha.
(Por todo esto, Francia fue condenada en 2015
por el Tribunal Europeo de Derechos Humanos
y más tarde en 2020 por un tribunal de París
por interferir en la investigación y presionar
a la defensa de la viuda de Bernard Borrel.)
Ya sabéis, la justicia y los derechos humanos
ante todo.
Otro caso bien documentado, poco conocido
y la prueba de que en ocasiones las operaciones
diseñadas en despachos a miles de kilómetros
acaban muy mal es el de Ruanda.
Me estoy refiriendo a cómo Francia de cierta
forma favoreció o ayudo al gobierno que propició
el genocidio de 1994.
Y es que veréis, Francia apoyó activamente
al gobierno liderado por los hutus hasta el
punto que proporcionó armas y entrenamiento
militar a las milicias hutus.
Armas y preparación que los hutus utilizaron
para masacrar a entre medio millón y un millón
de ciudadanos tutsis en apenas unos pocos
meses.
Pero África no es el único teatro de operaciones
en el que Francia se ha enfrentado a fuertes
polémicas.
Un ejemplo muy reciente lo tenemos en la guerra
de Yemen.
(Tanques Leclerc, proyectiles, aviones cazas
Mirage 2000-9, radares Cobra, blindados Aravis,
helicópteros Cougar y Dauphin, fragatas de
tipo Makkah, una corbeta lanza-misiles o cañones
Caesar,
Esta es parte de la larga lista del material
militar francés usado por Arabia Saudita
en la Guerra de Yemen.
Y es que a pesar de las reiteradas negativas
públicas del gobierno galo, todo apunta a
que en realidad Francia abrió de par en par
su catálogo de armas a los saudíes para
hacer un gran negocio con esta guerra.
Una guerra dónde la seguridad de los civiles
nunca fue una prioridad.)
Y no solo eso.
Todo apunta a que Francia también entrenó
y dio apoyo logístico a Arabia Saudita mientras
públicamente lo negaba.
Incluso existen informes creíbles que apuntan
a que Francia llegó a desplegar fuerzas especiales
en Yemen en el más absoluto secretismo.
(16/06/2018 Le Figaro: Fuerzas especiales
francesas sobre el terreno en Yemen.
Reuters.)
En fin, podríamos continuar con más y más
casos.
Lo cierto es que aunque los grandes medios
siempre se fijen en los escándalos y los
supuestos excesos de países como Estados
Unidos o Israel en el viejo continente también
tenemos lo nuestro.
Y en el caso particular de Francia su estatus
de país influyente en el mundo es algo que
se ha podido mantener a cambio de no respetar
ni promover siempre los derechos humanos,
la transparencia y la justicia.
Su influencia y, no nos engañemos, también
el negocio de su importantísima industria
militar.
Este es el precio de la “grandeza” de
Francia.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti.
¿Qué piensas de la política exterior de
Francia?
¿Cómo valoras su papel en África?
¿Creés que la consecución de intereses
y beneficios de diferente tipo justifica cualquier
intervención?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus respuestas.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a Like y Suscribirte a Visualpolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.